Jordan you are not a suicide economist
your mathematician so let's talk about
dot plot charts as a whole are they good
and telling a story yeah I actually love
this chart that we just saw I'm I know
it looks it looks kind of like the robot
like taking flight and turning into a
spaceship but it actually just as you
say it tells a story which numbers can
do and what the story that this tells is
each one of those dots on the screen
represents one economists forecast so
you're actually seeing not just one
person's forecast or a committee report
but actually each person's forecast
individually and what you can see is
that the long-term forecast everyone
kind of agrees it's kind of narrow
everyone agrees on what's gonna happen
but how we're gonna get there there's
many different stories and so you can
sort of see like where the where the
disagreement is among the economists in
the news business I try to use
percentages a lot to offer context for
viewers I find it's a good way of
putting things into perspective but
that's often misleading especially when
there are negative numbers involved can
you explain why this is exactly and of
course the percentage is a fabulously
useful tool that's why it's become so
common but like I'll give you an example
I really like that we talked a lot about
income inequality and income growth and
we say like something like 93 percent of
the growth in income in the recovery has
gone to the top one percent and that's
definitely true but the way it makes
that that makes it sound is that only
there's only 7 percent left for everyone
else and that's actually not true in
fact the top 10 percent is doing fine
and they've had lots of income growth -
but there's negative income growth for
everybody else the other 90% so in a way
saying it that way this 93 percent for
the top 1% kind of it puts everybody
else off the hook in a way that's not
really accurate it obscures right one of
the things you do in your book is you
don't obscure you illuminate and one of
you can just describe how you were able
to connect Al Gore George Bush and their
battle in Florida with slime mold
because you do that very well in the
book and I think that illustrates a lot
of what the book brings out but the
connection is not obvious I know so what
I talk about in the book and one thing
that mathematical analysis does is so
good at is connecting things that look
different on the surface but they have
similar underlying store
so a slime mold like a state or like a
country it's a collective organism right
it has to make decisions very simple
decisions in the slime molds case but it
doesn't have like a unified
consciousness that makes choices it has
a lot of little parts that have to
somehow make a decision collectively and
so this theory of collective
decision-making is something it's the
very frontier of math that people are
working on very actively and it applies
to both these kinds of biological
questions but also political questions
questions of how we as a nation make
aggregate decisions when obviously we
have very deep disagreements among
individuals and it had to do with the
choice between voting for Al Gore George
Bush or Ralph Nader correct right so
that's what's fascinating that we see
the same kind of phenomenon in the bio
lab as we did in Florida where the
presence of an extra alternative a third
party candidate can actually change the
calculus can actually change which of
two major candidates we decide between
you know I want to bring in something
else that of course has gotten a lot of
play among politicians as well the
student loan debt it has exploded
leaving a lot of people to fear that it
is a next subprime bubble talk to us
about how this chart which shows a
pretty straight line up fails to tell
the real story or the whole story wait
and it's always by the way these charts
they're always correct right so they're
not lying but there's always more to the
story than that so and what's definitely
true is the student loan is going up and
up by the way why that is it's still
kind of a mystery we argue about it all
the time everybody's sure they know why
but they all have different answers but
what's interesting is that there's a
super interesting distribution we can
say there's an average of about $25,000
of debt per per college graduate which
is a lot but the median is much smaller
it's about half that amount and there's
the story that that tells you is that
there's a few people who have a lot of
debt so you know if you see a story
somebody says oh how did that person
spend $150,000 on like a early Christian
philosophy degree what's their problem
that's like a very narrow slice what's
going on is about 1% of people have 200k
or more of debt that's like the 1% you
don't want to be in but but that's sort
of a lot of in some sense that's part of
the stories small numbers of people huge
amounts of debt but it's not the typical
case and it can lead to wrong policy in
some
I wonder our audience is made up of a
lot of math jockeys people who have
these massive degrees they're on Wall
Street they're always trying to price
risk on illiquid securities what can
they do better to use math to try to
price something so difficult to get your
head around I think if I did say one
thing I would love people to think more
about the notion of a probability
distribution okay so that's a technical
term but what it means is we don't just
ask about the average and we don't even
just ask about how much uncertainty is
will you ask really like what is the
likelihood it's like way out here what's
the likelihood it's in here it's kind of
this stuff it's like what Nate silver
brought to elections what he did like so
miraculously I would like to see that
kind of thinking everywhere in economics
too and of course among the most
technical people it is there all right
Jordan elenberg thank you so much better
how not to be wrong the power of
mathematical thinking